This lecture is about
how to do fast search by using inverted
index.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue the discussion of system
implementation.
In particular, we're going to talk
about how to support fast search by
using inverted index.
So let's think about what a general
scoring function might look like.
Now of course, the vector space model
is a special case of this, but we can
imagine many other retrieval functions
of the same form.
So the form of this function is as
follows.
We see this scoring function of
document d and query q is defined as
first a function of f(a).
That's adjustment function that would
consider two factors that are
shown here at the end f sub d of (d) and f
sub q of (q).
These are adjustment factors of
document and query so they are at the
level of a document and query.
And then inside of this function we
also see there's another function
called h.
So this is
the main part of the scoring function.
And these as I just said, are the
scoring factors at the level of the
whole document and query.
For example document lengths.
And this aggregate functioning would
then combine all these.
Now inside this edge function there are
functions that would compute the
weights of the contribution of a
matched query term t(i).
So this is g.
The function g gives us the weight of a
match query term t(i) in document
d.
And this h function would then
aggregate all these weights, so it will
for example, take a sum
of all the matched query terms.
But it can also be a product or could
be another way of aggregating them.
And then finally, this adjustment
function would
then consider the document level or query
level factors to further adjust
the score.
For example, documents normalization.
So this general form would cover many
state of the art retrieval functions.
Let's look at how we can
score documents with such a function
using inverted index.
So here's a general algorithm that
works as follows.
First these
query level and document level factors
can be precomputed in the indexing
time. Of course, for the query we have
the computed at query time, but for
document, for example, document lengths can
be precomputed.
And then we'll maintain a score
accumulator for each document d to
compute h.
And h is the aggregation function of
all the matched query terms.
So how do we do that?
Well, for each query term we're going
to fetch the inverted list from the
inverted index.
This would give us all the documents
that match this query term.
And that includes d1, f1
through dn, fn.
So each pair is document ID and
the frequency of the term in the document.
Then for each entry dj and fj
are particular match of the term
in this particular document dj.
We're going to compute the
function g.
That would give us something like a TF
if weights
of this term. So we'll compute the
weighted contribution of matching this
query term in this document.
And then we're going to update the
score accumulator for this document.
And this would allow us to add this to
a accumulator that would incrementally
compute the function h.
So this is basically a general way to
allow us to do computer all functions of
this form by using inverted index.
Note that we don't have to touch any
document that didn't match any query term.
But
this is why it's fast.
We only need to process the document
that matched at least one query term.
In the end, then, we're going to adjust
the score to compute this function
Fa, and then we can sort.
So let's take a look at the specific
example.
In this case, let's assume the scoring
function is very simple while it just
takes the sum of TF.
The raw TF.
The count of a term in the document.
Now this simplification would help
showing the algorithm clearly it's very
easy to extend the computation to
include other weights, like the
transformation of TF or document length
normalization or IDF weighting.
So let's take a look at a specific
example where the queries information
security.
And I show some entries of the inverted
index on the right side information
occurred four documents and their
frequencies.
Also their security occurred in three
documents.
So let's see how the algorithm works.
So first we iterate over all the query
terms.
An we fetch the first query them what
is that?
That's information.
Imagine we have all these
score accumulators to store the scores
for these
documents.
We can imagine there will be allocated
but then they will only be allocated as
needed.
So before we do any weighting of terms, we
don't even need a score
accumulator.
But conceptually we have these score
accumulators eventually allocated.
Let's fetch the entries from the
inverted list for information first.
That's the first one.
So these score accumulators obviously
will be initialized at 0.
So the first answer is d1 and 3.
3 is the
occurrences of information in this
document.
Since our scoring function assumes that
the score is just a sum of these raw
counts, we just need to add 3 to the
score accumulator to account for the
increase of score
due to matching this term information
in document d1.
And then we go to the next entry.
That's d2 and 4 and then we added
4 to the score accumulator of d2.
Of course, at this point that we will
allocated the score accumulator as
needed.
And so, at this point we allocated d1
and d2.
The next is d3 and we
add 1.
We allocate another score cumulative
for d3 and add 1 to it.
And then finding the d4 gets a 5
because the term
information occurred five times in this
document.
OK, so this completes the processing of
all the entries in the inverted index
for information. It processed all the
contributions of matching information
in these four documents.
So now our algorithm will go to the
next query term that security.
So we're going to fetch all the
inverted index entries for security.
So in this case there are three entries
and we're going to go through each of
them.
The first is d2 and 3, and that
means security occurs three times in
d2.
And what do we do?
Well, we do exactly the same as what we
did for information, so this time we're
going to change the score accumulator
d2, since it's already allocated.
And what we do is to add 3 to the
existing value which is 4.
So we now get the 7 for d2. d2 score is
increased because it matched both the
information and security.
Go to the next entry.
That's d4 and 1 so we would update
the score for d4 and again we add 1 to
d4.
So d4 now goes from 5 to 6.
Finally, we process d5 and 3.
Since we have not yet allocated a score
accumulator for d5.
At this point, we're going to allocate
1 for d5, and we're going to add 3 to it,
So those scores
on the last row are the final scores
for these documents
if our scoring function is just a
simple sum of TF values.
Now, what if we actually would like to
do length normalization?
We can do the normalization at this
point for each document.
So to summarize this you can see we
first processed the
query term information.
We processed all the entries in the
inverted index for this term.
Then we processed the security.
It's worth thinking about what should
be the order of processing here.
when we consider query terms.
It might make difference, especially if
we don't want to keep all the score
accumulators.
Let's say we only want to keep the most
promising score accumulators.
What do you think it would be a good
order to go through?
Would you go.
Would you process a common term first
or would you process a rare term first?
The answer is we should
process the rare term first.
A rare term would match fewer documents
and then the score contribution would
be higher because the idea of value
will be higher.
And then it allows us to touch the
most promising documents first, so it
helps pruning some non promising ones
if we don't need to so many documents
to be returned to the user.
Right, so those are all heuristics for
further improving the accuracy here.
You can also see how we can incorporate
the IDF weighting so they can easily
be incorporated when we process each
query term.
When we fetch the inverted index, we
can fetch the document frequency and
then we can compute the IDF.
Or maybe perhaps the IDF value has
already been precomputed.
When we index the documents at that
time, we already computed the IDF value
that we can just fetch it.
So all these can be done at this time,
so that would mean when we process all
the entries for information, these
weights will be adjusted by the same
IDF, which is IDF for information.
So this is the basic idea of using
inverted index for faster search and it
works well for all kinds of formulas
that are of the general form. This
general form covers
actually most state of the art
retrieval functions.
So there are some tricks to further
improve the efficiency.
Some general techniques
include the caching.
This is just to store some results of
popular queries so that next time when
you see the same query, you simply
return the stored results.
Similarly, you can also store the list
of inverted index in the memory for
popular term and if the query terms are
popular, likely you will soon need to
fetch the inverted index for the same
term again.
So keeping them in the memory would help
and these are general techniques for
improving efficiency.
We can also keep only the most
promising accumulators because a user
generally doesn't want to examine so
many documents.
We only need to return high quality
subset of documents that likely are
ranked on the top. For that purpose,
we can then prune the accumulators.
We don't have to store all the
accumulators.
At some point, we just keep the
highest value accumulators.
Another
technique is to do parallel processing and
that's needed for really processing
such a large data set like the web data
set and to scale up to the web scale,
we need a special to have special
techniques to do parallel processing
and to distribute the storage of files
on multiple machines.
So here, as here's a list of some text
retrieval tool kits, it's not a
complete list.
You can find more information at this
URL on the bottom.
Here is the four here
Lucene is one of the most popular toolkits
that can support a lot of applications
and it has very nice support for
applications.
You can use it to build a search engine
application very quickly.
The downside is that it's not that easy to
extend it
and algorithms implemented there also
not the most advanced algorithms.
Lemur/Indri is another tool kit
that
does not have such a nice support for
application as lucene, but it has
many advanced search algorithms.
And it's also easy to extend.
Terrier is yet another tool kit that
also has good support for application
capability and some advanced
algorithms, so that's
maybe in between Lemur or Lucene or
maybe rather combining the strength of
both, so that's also a useful tool kit.
MeTA is the tool kit that we will use for the
programming assignment and this is a
new tool kit that has a combination of
both text retrieval algorithms and text
mining algorithms.
And so topic of all those models are
implemented there.
There are
a number of text analysis
algorithms implemented in the toolkit
as well as basic search
algorithms.
So to summarize, all the discussion
about the system implementation, here
are the major takeaway points.
Inverted index is the primary data
structure for supporting a search
engine.
That's the key to enable faster
response to a user's query.
And the basic idea is to preprocess
the data as much as we can,
and we want to do compression when
appropriate so that we can save disk
space and can speed up IO and
processing of inverted index.
In general we talked about how to
construct the inverted index when the
data can't fit into the memory, and then
we talk about the fast search using
inverted index.
Basically to exploit the inverted index
to accumulate the scores for documents
matching or query term.
And we explore the Zipf's law to avoid
attaching many documents that don't
match any query term.
And this algorithm can for his support
a wide range of ranking algorithms.
So these basic techniques have great
potential for further scaling up using
distributed file system, parallel
processing and caching.
Here are two additional readings that
you can take a look if you have time
and you're interested in learning more
about this.
The first one is a classic textbook
about the efficiency of
Inverted index and compression
techniques and how to in general build
efficient search engine in terms of the
space, overhead and speed.
The second one is a newer textbook that
has a nice discussion of implementing
and evaluating search engines.